foreign
welcome so please ask any questions you
like during this tutorial it's supposed
to be pretty basic stuff so apologies to
the experts in the area will be bored
um but um I'll be talking about
connections between pseudor Randomness
and learning
and
so Randomness is really about
structure hidden within Randomness so
that even though there's some structure
you cannot really tell sorry
that was a question so yeah please do
ask questions so so the randomness is
like you're hiding structure within
Randomness so that nobody can tell if
there's something structured is hidden
within Randomness and learning is kind
of like the opposite uh you're given
something which has structure hidden in
it or some present in it and like maybe
surrounded by by Randomness and you're
trying to learn that structure kind of
distinguish it from random extracted
from Randomness in some way
so to the randomness and learning seem
to have this kind of conflict between
them so one is Possible only if the
other one is not
and that will be the subject of my first
hour of talk
um where we'll be using mcsp
algorithms or heuristics for mcspe to
break to the randomness to show that
this is not possible which would imply
that this is possible so that you can
have learning
okay so that will be this
beginning
so before I get more formal
let me show you some random picture of a
jungle
uh it's supposed to be jungle I think in
Northern India somewhere so that gives
enough information to figure out what is
in there
can you see
it's the same picture
and looking at Eric do you see tiger in
there I still see it is it supposed to
be a colorblindness test no no well
[Music]
it depends who you are
if you're somebody here then you'll see
this picture and because you cannot
distinguish red from Green
if you a longer monkey then you'll see
an or a human as it turns out you you
will see this picture so you'll be able
to easily tell a red colored tiger from
the green forage okay so depending on
the power of your test or your Observer
something may look pretty
indistinguishable from random
uh or something definitely is
distinguishable from random by a big
life-saving margin
so this is pseudor Randomness kind of in
a nutshell uh but there's more going on
here
um so as I mentioned like this monkey
and by the way they often cooperate with
the deer so they act like as a Sentry
for the deer to make sure that the deer
who suffer from this filtering will not
be eaten by Tiger
um so this guy is going to distinguish
Randomness from uh something that
contains a tiger in it and intuitively
there's a good chance that monkey can't
can see the tiger itself so monkey can
also learn with tiger so like if you can
distinguish Randomness from
a structure then you're in a good
position to learn what is hidden within
that Randomness and that's exactly what
I'm going to be talking about next
so let me Define the learning model
um so we'll talk about uh learning model
due to Valiant filing stock
probabilistically approximal learning
where you have uniform distribution and
I'm going to allow it membership I'm
going to allow membership queries as
opposed to just random labeled examples
as would be the standards for valiant's
model
so the picture looks like this you have
a learning algorithm that tries to learn
something like a tiger in some
complexity Class C is a Boolean function
from some class of concept C and the
learning algorithm has access to like
black box access can ask Oracle
questions to this function uh ask for
input X get back the value of the
function on the table back so like can
play the Oracle f for a bunch of times
and then maybe use some Randomness and
with some decently high probability
close to one I would put a circuit which
may not compute the function of exactly
but it's like Epsilon closed where
Epsilon close means that it agrees with
the function on all inputs except maybe
like Epsilon fraction
so that's the model
again
right so this probability is over the
randomness of the learning algorithm and
uh so this high probability over its
internal Randomness learning all of them
will produce a good circuit
and a circuit is considered to be good
if it agrees with the function on most
inputs
so this is the uniform distribution that
I mentioned here so the success of the
learning algorithms output the
hypothesis that is produced by learning
algorithm is judged by how close it
approximates the function in question
where the closeness is with respect to
the specific uniform distribution in PAC
model it can be arbitrary distribution
that you have no clue about but this is
just for specific uniform distribution
yeah thank you very much the Assumption
and scores
function is worst case yeah so well in
in the sense that um function can be
anything
yeah yeah it's not a distribution over
functions that's a very good there I'll
get back to that thank you
so that's the definition for the
learning part so for pseudonymous part
maybe it's a purpose but let me still
Define what pseudo Randomness means and
um it's Randomness that I'll be talking
about will come in like in two flavors
even though I'll focus on a second
failure but I will Define both so
there's a crypto Randomness and
complexity to the randomness by sort of
Randomness here it means to the random
generators
um so for crypto So Random generators
um are equivalent to one with functions
by this famous result due to hospital 11
and Luby
and for complexity Ram generators their
existence is equivalent to Circuit lower
bounds by this beautiful connection
between hardness and Randomness due to
Nissan readers and some follow-up work
so the generator is this object
uh which is an algorithm which takes
some string and outputs a longer string
usually longer string
and the definition of it being good
being pseudorandom is that the output of
the generator kind of looks like it is
uniformly random string to a
computationally bounded Observer like if
you're a monkey then it's very difficult
for you or if you're jeer even more
difficult for you to tell
um something output by the generator
from the random thing
and uh these two settings I mentioned
crypto and complexity
so in the crypto World
um your adversary can be an arbitrary
size circuit polynomial size circuit but
of arbitrary polynomial size
um and you also required you the
generator is also required to work in
polynomial time in the seat size so it
should be very efficient and full lots
of adversaries so your life is really
difficult
whereas in the complexity world you're
told in advance that you'll be fooling
size and square circuits for example so
you don't need to full m Cube just n
square and moreover you're allow it to
run in time which is like exponential in
the seat size so life is relatively easy
however
um so because like the Restriction here
or the demands here are much more
stringent
um showing that or killing the crypto
generator is relatively easy
whereas killing the complexity generator
is more difficult
right because it's so close to the real
thing maybe
and so intuitively if you have something
which kills complexity generator then
you should get better bang for your buck
and that's exactly what happens and that
will be the question was raised earlier
[Music]
so if you manage to kill cryptographics
to random generators then you do get
learning but the learning will not be
worst case but on average
and that's exactly the point and this is
from an old paper by Big Lots 11 and
there's some follow-up word by bomb
first terms and Lipton and now we're in
yogip who show this connection so
basically if you break crypto prgs then
you get something for learning but that
something is unfortunately only on
average
whereas if you break the complexity prg
which as I said is more difficult to do
then you get to learning in the worst
case
okay and this is what I'm going to talk
about this is based on the work of
impact lots and bigderson a different
paper from 98 from 2001 Journal version
and also work with karmacino uh in
paglazzo and Kola that I'll focus on
most
all right so what are the complexity
generators and I'm not gonna give like
full details of course uh in this
tutorial but I wanted to give some
flavor of the very famous complexity of
pseudonym generator due to Nissan
winterson
I won't Define it very formally but I'll
give you the properties of this
generator
so this is a generator which based on
some function f
think of it as maybe a heart function so
that the pseudonymous of the generator
will depend on the corners of the
functions it will be the harder the
function the more secure the generator
intuitively
and this generator based on this
function will have some stretch some
non-trivial stretch that you can control
you would the designer can control how
much you want to stretch and say my
generator uh will map and square bit
strange to some capital L by strengths
where L can be as big as exponential but
not too big so like at most to the n
ope and the nice thing about this
generator which is shared by some other
constructions that I'll mention later is
that breaking this generator gives you
something nice in this context it will
give you a learning algorithm for the
function f that the generator was based
on
and the way it comes about
is through this picture here
so suppose your generator is broken by a
distinguisher d what what it means it
means that there's a distinguisher d who
tells uh with noticeable Advantage the
case of the output coming from a random
generator versus the uniform of the
random distribution
then you're learning algorithm with help
from this distinguisher so it's learned
with Oracle access to D
will act will be able to learn F and it
will ask some membership queries as we
discussed in the model of learning that
we're using here and after some
polynomial amount of time uh using some
random mass will spit out a circuit
which will be a good circuit for the
function f how good under the form
distribution it will approximate the
function f better than one half so it's
going to be half plus some parameter
with where the parameter depends on the
output of the generator and it's not
what we quite want it's like a weak
learning model but it can be boosted to
uh strong learning and I'll talk about
that later
so the important thing is that the
runtime of the Gen uh the runtime of the
learning algorithm is like polynomial
in the output size of the generator
so if you want the generator to run fast
um and you want to learn some function f
on N inputs this n Square
by the way will be exactly the same n
as your function as input size so if you
want to learn function f I'm input size
n and you use this generator you want to
learn it fast in polynomial in time in n
and then you want to make this capital L
to be polynomialism
which is kind of the opposite of what
you do in like randomization where this
generators come from where you want to
stretch by a lot because you want you're
so greedy you want to have as many
random bits as you possibly can uh you
don't want fused random bits
but from purpose for the purposes of
learning
um not being greedy is better because it
gives you more efficiency can you go
back so you assume that this is taking
food some flattened functions so here
here it's like a it's a template
construction of this procedure which
Maps short strings to Long strings uh
where the stamplet contains a place for
function f of your choosing
and you can plug in for f anything you
like
and the property you'll get if you
manage to distinguishly this generally
if you manage to break this generator
then you'll learn this function f that
you plug it in
and then because it's worst case
function you can pick it any way you
like you'll be able to learn every
function you like so that will be worth
this learned
yeah as I said it's a weaker learning
and we'll have uh we're gonna get struck
summary from it by doing some kind of
boosting arguments that I'll talk about
later
foreign
amous and learning are of course
examples of meta complexity problems
um but there's also like a commagore
relative that is going to be crucial for
for the story uh which is mcsp
e because mcsp is like an ultimate
generator killer
so it can kill pretty much any generator
complexity one or cryptographic one you
name it
because intuitively the generators
are defined in such a way that the
output of the generator is compressible
to the seed
right that's the definition generator
that you take a c that you expand it
computationally so this the output
generator is compressible thinking about
the opposite direction and mcsp or
relative for common core complex
relatives are exactly those algorithms
which will tell you if you're given if
you're given string is compressible or
not
so the output of the generator is
compressible therefore mcsp will say hey
it's compressible and most random
strings by counting have huge common
growth complexity essentially
incompressible
so like on random stuff mcsp algorithm
will say most likely not compressible on
pseudor random stuff it will say
compressible for sure
so it will break your pseudonym
generator like that
the definition of inside circuit problem
I don't have to Define it but I will uh
is given a truth table of a function f
so the full truth table of size 2 little
n for your functional and bits and a
precise parameter s somewhere between 0
and 2 VM the question is is that
computable by Boolean Circuit of size at
most s
uh let's define this already but just in
case
and
the property
of this Nissan vickerson generator
is so-called locality and this is the
term that rasborv introduced uh when he
used to run generators in transcription
once uh for the study of proof
complexity so there's another connection
between pseudor Randomness and proof
complexity and he used this application
generators and he observed this locality
property what is locality property
basically there's like a technical
definition slides electrical definition
that I'm going to say but basically
locality means that mcsp will break your
generator
okay so if you're generating you're
generating local if and only if it's
breakable by mcspeak of some sort
uh more precisely locality means that on
any seat to the generator so say you
have function f that generator is based
on coming from some size as circuit
class so f is computable by power and
outside circuit Okay then if you use any
c to the generator the output of the
generator using your function and let's
see it as when viewed as a truth table
of a Boolean function so you have here
short string policy to the generator and
slightly longer output which you think
of as a truth table of a function on
like log of the length of the string
inputs right so if the output or
generators of size capital L I will
always think of capital L is equal to 2
the little l so my function here is the
truth table of a function of little L
inputs
and the locality means that that
function on little L inputs has small
size how big is going to be circuit size
of this function is going to be the size
of s which is the function f that you
use to build this generator plus and
polynomial over a hat
which comes from the inner workings of
the Nissan of interesting generator
okay so what does it give you the
ability to break the outputs of the
generator
um
about locality versus non-locality you
explain how mcsp breaks any prg and then
you said it's local fmcsp breaks it
Yeah so
basically mcsk breaks a generator
because the output of a generator is
compressible yeah right but now uh what
kind of and so what is what does mcsq
want it's not just it's compressible but
it has small circuit complexities
like for example it may be compressible
but in a way um but the sort of
complexity may not understand will be
small
but there may be different way to
compress it rather than use small
circuit to describe it
so depending on who's looking at the
output version generators some things
may be breakable and unbreakable
depending on the power of the drawer
even though a drawer may be like mcsp or
a relative romantic speed I'll talk
about some other common or complexion
measure in a second half of mind so so
technically the locality of the
generator means that the output of the
generator due to the truth table is
locally computable easily
uh it looks like computable means there
is a small circuit which computes any
location on the output or generator
that's why you think of it as a truth
table we have like a small circuit which
computes this truth table locality means
that this is a small circuit so you can
compute locally in any position
and the size of the small circuit will
basically be a function of the size of
the function f you start from plus and
polynomial over half
so if you choose the parameters properly
this size will be relatively small for
truth tables of a given length and then
your mcsp with appropriate digital
threshold parameter will say ah this is
easy because it has multiple size
so
basically the output of the true of the
generator is like linked to the little l
and the size of the circuit that
computes this output is this S Plus poly
n so there's a bit of translation that
you need to do to express this as
possible and in terms of your input size
which is little l
and like I won't do the calculations but
I'll show you some two interesting cases
you have exponential scratch so your
capital L is actually the little n
roughly and you start with a function f
which is computable by polynomial side
service
and then the alphabet generator will be
size
polynomial in l
because there's a common million S Plus
um
on 1 million and so L is following n so
everything's normal
so the point is that you have a
potential stretch uh the output of the
generator is has polymer for the defaxes
another example and this will be the
setting that will will actually
use as much
but this is the more standard setting
where we have a huge stretch
oh
um backwards yeah registration results
and stretch so if you have stretch
polynomial they're small and this is a
setting actually warmth we have
polynomial stretch therefore our
learning algorithm will be fast we'll
run the polynomial time but you have to
pay for it if you have polynomial
stretch then your input size will be
like log n for your function and the
size of your function will be based on
this formula
over here
if you plug in those parameters the
output of the generator viewed as a
truth table or function on L bits will
be of exponential size in l
so the output is still small but it now
has exponential circuit complexity
so to break this thing with mcsb mcsp
has to work harder because now you have
small difference between like
exponentially but less than maximum and
random which is basically maximum so a
very small Gap
uh in the second case for so mcsb really
has to work very hard to distinguish the
small Gap versus the first case where
mcsp has it relatively easy you have
like exponentially ran for random things
with exponential High complexity and for
your things it's like problems I have a
huge gap between polymer links Financial
references
easy heart
in this case you have learning algorithm
which is shop exponential because we
didn't work hard enough
in this case because you work so hard
you get a surprise Palm on real-time
learning numbers
so just again a pictorial explanation of
why is in San Francisco G local
basically
um given the seat the generator based on
the function f computes the values of
the function f from some strings which
come from the seed
they have some non-trivial overlaps
and which portions of the seed should be
used as an input for which copy of the
function f here uh is modeled by some
natural structure called design in
something different design basically it
tells you the partitioning or
partitioning of the seed into
overlapping inputs of the right size and
you apply F function to each one of
those and output is the output of the
generator
so ignoring this
fact that the inputs are kind of
overlapping here
the truth table output by the generator
if you want to compute the position I
you just need to apply the function f
to appropriate inputs and out comes the
bit in position I and because the
function f itself has more sort of
complexity
you can compute each bit of the
generator output by small circuit
complexity intuitively
polyam comes from the design computation
so there is a little bit of work if you
tell me the index I I need to figure out
which subset of the bitlication of the
seat to use to to apply your circuit for
F2
and that's a polynomial overhead
fortunately the designs themselves can
be efficiently constructed so it's an
explicit construction of how to
partition things and this is permanent
overhead that we can tolerate
I thought explicit one was only with
small stretch right but if you have
blood stretch exactly the case we want
small stress okay so in the large
threats case we don't know of a local PG
this super large smoke trash we don't
have a we don't have a good design
construction but
super like exponential stretch will give
you like exponential time learning
algorithm so I don't know if you're
really willing to pay for exponential
time running algorithm
let's go to trivia one there may become
small constant Improvement
um so yeah it's like exponential stretch
where these guys are hard to find
um may not be even worth doing but
honestly I'm not sure what happens we
don't know any better than this greedy
algorithm that's right that's right
that's right yeah
how do you think central Time regime
maybe exponential time is okay for you
to pay right
because you want to be running an
exponential time just learning all this
but anyway so maybe it's okay you can
absorb those costs possibly I haven't
thought about bits to guns
yes
before
[Music]
could you have a question so the
question is and then somebody also can
can answer and I can look at the answer
why did transport of need locality in
his paper improve complexity
yeah
because you want to show it's hard to
prove mcsp natural properties from just
a proof complexity generator which is
it's the same thing is right right why
you need it here
once I repeated it I think it's 2002 but
okay maybe it was yeah yeah it's a long
time
it's good to repeat question sometimes
um
right so how do we use this mcsp to
learn uh we play to lose
and this is a nice way to play so you
set up uh the game in such a way that
you will definitely lose at the game so
I suggest you all do that
and so in this case what it means is you
set the parameters of your generator
like a stretch parameter in such a way
that mcsp will have easy time breaking
it
and why why are you rooting for mcsp
because if mcsp breaks your generator
you get a learning algorithm
you want to get learning you want the
generator to fail to to be broken by
mcsp and you set the parameter so that
it does happen and as I said you like
want to polynomial time algorithm so you
want to get a polynomial scratch
and your mcsp will work very hard so you
set the threshold parameter to be like
exponential in L where L is the input
size of your function and by choosing
the parameters appropriately the outputs
of the generator based on function f say
of polynomial size will be of
exponential but smaller than to the L
over two circuit complexity whereas for
your random string it complexity will be
close to 2 the L
so have a gap between two the over 2 and
2 the L
um and therefore your mcsp will be able
to break the generator
and it will do it in polynomial time for
you because the stretch we set was
polynomial in the both sides of the
function afterwards
okay so in the end you get venison
algorithm that will compute the function
app so it will produce a circuit which
computes the function f uh significantly
more than 50 of the time
this one over poly was one over capital
L before for people who are like
following this so still
um and our stretches Palm one also it's
non-trivial Advantage over half this is
with an MCT work this is yeah you see it
right here yeah
yeah
definitely
we'll we'll work on that
but yes thank you for observing this
yeah definitely so mcsp uh is used by
the Learning algorithm to get a learning
algorithm with membership queries on
over the uniform distribution and we
haven't gotten even the function f
approximated well enough it's only like
better than 50 but that's easy to fix
foreign
to get this result you just set the
polynomial stretch and set the
parameters appropriately and things just
work out
so let me talk about some improvements
you can do
first we can make a better learner so
instead of like better than 50 of the
time you can get your function 99 of the
time
by doing the boosting trick also known
by the name of Yao's exor Lemma
um so instead of learning
function f that you actually want to
learn
uh you'll Define the new function f
Prime which is uh
which is like xor of K copies of the
function f on K independent inputs so F
Prime is given uh K independent inputs
X1 for x k you apply F to each one of
them and then X or the result so F Prime
is also a Boolean function since F was a
Boolean function and moreover F Prime is
not much more difficult than F was
because we're basically using f and use
the circuit for f like K times if K is
small and it will be small it will be
more polynomial and N then the circuit
for f Prime will also have polynomial
size because the function f was of
polynomial circuit complex
so now we like
switch the game for the poor learning
algorithm so now the learning algorithm
must learn F Prime instead of F and
we'll do so only with like better than
50 chance
but it's good enough if we get F Prime
better than 50 chance uh Advantage then
there's a way to recover from it a small
circuit for original function f that we
care about and that will compute the
function f with 99 chance
actually one minus one over poly
so this is kind of a boosting where you
have a weak learner and you use it to
get a strong learner by taking the
function you want to learn and kind of
encode it in some error correctly way
and then run the weak learner on the
encoded function and do the decoding of
the encoding to recover the circuit for
original function
foreign
CSP
so now Things become a little bit more
interesting or quite a bit more
interesting I would say
uh
because
you know the Oracle for mcsp was a bit
too much
to break the generator that we set up
it's really enough to distinguish the
outputs of the generator from random
so I don't really need to be able to
tell on every simple string simple truth
table if it's simple but just on average
okay
so I don't really need a strong
algorithm like an mcsp algorithm
but I can get away with something which
is like an average case heuristic for
mcsp
another way if um yeah so
so an efficient heuristic for mcsp would
be an algorithm P which has the
following property
uh for all for every easy truth table
like easy think about small size like
polynomial size for example the
heuristic algorithm says yes easy 100
correct
and on a random one
um it may say sometimes easy sometimes
hard but for at least fifty percent of
the random strengths the algorithm will
say no it doesn't seem to be easy
so sometimes it says known easy things
but you know easy things are very few
the fact that the algorithm says yes on
all the easy ones is a huge advantage
because they so so sparse in this whole
Space of random things that being able
to say yes on all the easy ones and have
some tiny error on the rest is huge
very useful yes
and this definition is exactly or pretty
much the same as the definition of a
natural property given by rasborough
when rudich in the context of circuit
complexity that Rahul talked about
in their language it would be like a
natural property useful against size s
where s is this size parameter for the
easy functions
equivalently you can take talk and talk
about this as like zero error average
case uh heuristic for mcsp or I talk a
thing about it is like one-sided average
case heuristic which turns out to be
exactly the same thing for this problem
even though General like one-sided and
zero error is not the same but like for
this problem it just happens
uh and why I call it one-sided is
because you always have to be correct on
the easy ones
so on this side you're always correct
and here for random ones I give you some
slack but because there are so many hard
ones that being correct on there
sometimes of that's okay it's okay it's
minor minor offense for now
the good thing about this is that um
such heuristic algorithms
are enough
for the learning application that I'm
told you about so Nissan victorson just
needs to be broken
you don't have to have mcsp algorithm to
break it you just have to have something
which will always output yes on this to
the random part which happens to be easy
and heuristic here gives you that and on
the random things it will not say easy
too often
so that's enough
okay so now the Robert's question so
finally we can have a setup where we can
get rid of this mcsp Oracle and get an
unconditional learning algorithm for
some circuit class using this framework
I described
and what we're going to learn is the
class of ac0 circuits with multiplicates
from for Prime P so ac0 mod PK it's a
circuit of constant depth
with ands ORS and not Gates as well as
some mod P Gates which for the purpose
of the stock will be denoted by plus
like priorities
um
but parity can be more to P gate for any
Prime p
so these circuits are
some it's a model that we understand
reasonably well
and there are strong lower bounds known
for explicit functions like majority uh
against this class of circuits so like
majority requires Circuit of this type
of exponential size so exponential like
until they enter the Epsilon kind of
exponential let's call it weekly
exponential side
these are famous results from the Golden
Era of circuit complexity of
deuterasworld and smolensky
moreover such lower bounds
contained in them something nice namely
mcsb heuristics so the proofs of this
lower bounds are natural in a sense that
you can extract from them
um and average case algorithm for ac0
multi-pmcsp version
thinking about this it's like pretty
amazing that rasborough and rudich in
their natural
proofs paper
um showed this result and they had to
work pretty hard
to take this rasbros malinsky lower
bound and make it into an algorithm and
their purpose was just to make a point
that their notion of natural proofs is
universe is applicable to all the lower
bounds up to date
and so they were not lazy to take time
and figure out how to do it for ac0 mod
P circuits but for them and just like
another case in their longest paper
saying oh this is natural proof this
natural proof this natural proof and
yeah this is look doesn't look very
natural to begin with but with some work
we can make it natural as well and they
did
and finally sorry
what did they have to do while you
wasn't it natural
they have to do something in your
algebra
how to make it natural make it large
enough make it large enough yes yes
so the largest was not there to begin
with so they had to argue that the
Learners can be made sufficient and that
involves some looking inside and opening
the Black Box figuring out what's what
it's reliable
and they came up with uh average age
heuristic for mcsp for h0 multi circuits
for size up to weekly expansion so again
it's not full-fledged mcsp it's not
worst case it's on the average it's for
a special class x015 and even then the
size parameter cannot be very large but
it's obviously exponential so that's
great
that's what I just said
so now to learn a function f which has
polynomial say size circuits of this
type ac0 mod P
um
we need to play this game
uh play to lose game and as I mentioned
before the runtime of your learning
algorithm that you get so now think
about you have some kind of mcsp Oracle
average case which is good enough so now
we're playing the game that I described
earlier just going to set the scratch
and play to lose so that the mcsp
algorithm of raspberry and rootage will
break the generator ideally we would
like to set the strategy polynomial and
then we will get a polynomial time
learning algorithm that would be too
good to be true
um so it turns out that you set the
stretch to be quasi polynomial rather
than polynomial and the reason it has to
be quasi polynomial and polynomial is
that their average case algorithm
doesn't work for exponential circuit
complexity but only weekly exponential
sort of complexity okay so they left
something for us to do
um so we call exponential circuit lower
bounds is the best we know so far and
there's a good reason for why
but weekly exponential gives you quasi
polynomial stretch is sufficient and so
you'll get quite a pollen enough time
learning algorithm
so it works out that capital is quite a
polynomial little L the input size of
your function that you're going to be
um that's the output of the truth table
uh the truth output by the generator
will be of size to the lll so L's will
be the complexity of the parameter and
the threshold is said to be exponential
typically exponential in little L and
the output or generator generator is too
little L which is to the poly log which
is part of the polynomial
and as a result you get unconditional
randomized quasi polynomial time
learning algorithm for responsive
circuits x0.p
under the uniform distribution only n
with membership queries unfortunately
mcsp has been taken care of
previously
a famous result by Lionel Mansour Nissan
gave a randomized quasi polynomial time
learning algorithm for ac0 so without
multi Gates
and their approach was quite different
um their learning algorithm was also
used was also using our understanding of
ac0 functions some easy ic0 functions
and the property those guys have but
those properties are taken care of by
some kind of Fourier reasoning and so
they use Fourier analysis of Woodland
functions to get the learning algorithm
um we use pseudorandom generators
and the connection between circuit
complexity and pseudorandom generators
to get this result for ac01 p circuits
like Fourier doesn't seem to be enough
for for our purposes for learning there
possibility to use the same approach but
for the c0 it's like your approach
very good question so
if I understand your question correctly
are you saying like can we break the prg
for function f coming from X to Zero and
get the same result yes you can
um because ac0 is a subsidy zero most P
so for a trivial reason you can learn
HCC around however
is similar right very good very good
however unfortunately
um the locality of the Nissan
vehicle term to compute the designs
which is fast Poland
and there's an efficient way to
Computing the designs which
unfortunately use some mod Gates
so we cannot really compute the designs
or ac0 Style
actually there's a lower bound that ac0
circuits cannot compute designs with the
properties that we want
so you cannot use the same framework
unfortunately for ac0 with a simple or
natural property phrase zero because of
an extra overhead of the prg that is
yeah very good question so thank you so
much
no questions
yeah please this is easy
zero Computing these is this for um
just specifically these combinatorial
designs or just for any like
construction that has this
reconstruction property
yeah so it's basically portfolio
definition of designs that you want you
want a function that splits the set into
subsets with small overlap okay it has
enough of them so if you want the
properties like that then ac0 cannot
compute those things
yeah so I just um
find it in a nice lucky coincidence that
raspber when rudich took their time to
come up with a one-sided average case
heuristic for ac0 remote pmcsp and
finally it has found its Niche and an
application in the constructive way of
getting learning algorithms so somebody
uh so often teacher course and
algorithms and uh some somebody said
that like if you have a good algorithm
somebody will find a way to use it for
good so here you have a good algorithm
for natural property for ac0 mod P but
finally it was used
for good for good not just to prove a
point but actually
um
to summarize what I said so far
um Nissan generator a particular version
of complexity generator that was useful
for this purposes plus mtsp heuristic or
average case heuristic also known as
natural property
uh two ingredients that can give you
learning algorithms
in the general setting and if you can
instantiate that like for x0 remote P
you get rid of mcsp because there's an
actual algorithm there and you get this
kind of learning
um
one thing that would be nice to get is
um learning from random examples alone
and you don't use membership queries
that would for ac0 mod P for example
okay we have unconditional algorithm
that learns a0 remote P but uses
membership queries
lineal Mansour and Nissan managed to
learn ac0 with just random examples no
membership queries
here we need to use random examples
because we need to use this
incentivization generator intuitively it
would be very interesting to get rid of
the Snapchat craze I think you would
have to do something completely
different that's why it's an interesting
question
you know just like look at things
maybe you can I don't know maybe I wish
I can I'm sure but it's a difficult
question what would require new insights
okay so I have a few more minutes
um
to tell you about more abstract
framework
so if you think back what we did with
new zombie Gibson generator
is uh it's a special case of the
following more General scheme
so you have some secret strength call it
f
um so here in green it's what we did for
Nissan Wickerson and on the left hand
side I'm saying uh what will be like the
general framework
so how you can think of somebody just a
special case of a more General thing
they have some secret string F function
you want to learn truth table of
function you want to learn
then you have some kind of generator
in our case it was in San Francisco
generator based on the function f in
general it will be generator which will
use the secret string in some way
okay and we'll we'll have some stretch
mapping relatively short string to
relatively long strings
okay then your task
will be to distinguish the generator's
output from uniformly random
why would you want to do that
because the price you get if you do so
will be an algorithm to reconstruct your
secret f
assuming your generator has some
reconstruction property that I'm going
to Define in a moment
which was the case for Nissan victorson
so what's the construction property is
what you think it is if you have a
distinguisher for your generator G sub F
then you get from it an algorithm to
compute F or maybe approximately or
maybe exactly depends on the generator
you use
given maybe some short advice
okay so what was it for the NW
applications that we talked about
earlier you had a circuit Which computes
F approximately
and the advice you need is evaluations
of your function f on a few inputs
if you if you have such a thing you can
get an algorithm to compute a string
given some Store Short advice it's
another way of saying that your string F
has small time-bounded Commonwealth
complexity because you can compute F
efficiently have an algorithm for that
and to to do the computation you only
need to be given some short advice so
that's the Commodore description that
you've given to your reconstruction
algorithm and then your construction
algorithm Works efficiently and you
compute the string f
okay so if this framework works then you
get some sense of an upper bound on the
Commodore complex time-bounded Common
Ground complexity of your string f
using this framework
and as I suggested we all should play to
lose
um so you choose your GF carefully
so that the outputs of your generator is
compressible for bringing some rigorous
and it was captured by the definition of
locality of the generator
and then you use some heuristic that can
test for compressibility
I used this mcsp heuristic or average
case of this one-sided version of mcsp
but you can use any of the common growth
complexity measures that you know and
are friends with
here yes
and if you do so then you get the meta
complexity heuristic here that is useful
like if it's like yeah I'm going to get
to that point in a moment but like this
Meta Meta complex the heuristic here
will allow you to learn F or construct F
which will give you an upper bound on
the chemical complexity of f so a
commonwealth complexities used in two
places like assumption and the
conclusion
right
and this brings us to this bridge
between worst case and average case
complexity
um
so as I just mentioned uh to break the
generator G sub F you only need to have
some average case heuristic maybe
one-sided or zero error once whichever
you like
so this is an average case assumption
but the algorithm is yet to recover a
secret string f is worst case it works
for every f
okay so your assumption is about average
case easiness so something is easy to do
on average your conclusion is that worst
case every string F has small homograph
complexity of time-bounded kind
so natural property for our example that
we used before it's an average case
heuristic
average case algorithm and by the way we
don't know like worst case heuristic for
mcsp mod P that would be amazing if we
did but average case is enough and
that's that was lucky
but average case heuristic here gives
you worst case learning algorithm
s and this bridge from average case
heuristics for compressibility using
this a generator based approach to worst
case conclusions is something that
Trisha herahara really took to the next
level and he'll talk about in his talk
at some point here in the boot camp
I just want to finish by mentioning a
couple of examples of generators that
what can you use so nwprgs is just one
example you can use other prgs and I'll
talk about some of them in the next hour
you can also use extractors which are
other kinds of generators
or you can use something very simple
like direct product constructions maybe
some air correcting codes direct product
construction off or just take a function
and do the jackpot construction of the
function and I'll mention some of those
things in my next hour
but the point is you have a framework
and then it's up to your imagination
What kind of generators to plug in and
what kind of consequences to get
so you have lots of
objects out there on the Shelf to play
with so just figure out what works for
what
and applications of this kind of
approach is to learning that we talked
about
worst case to average case reductions
for NP
that I mentioned Teresa might talk about
this problem that Rahul mentioned
understanding the relationship between
algorithmica and heuristica or in other
words if you have like an average case
algorithm for sat can you solve that
worst case efficiently or somewhat
efficiently okay can you convert average
cases of sound into worst cases in a
sub-south in some way
as well as some circuit lower bounds for
mcsp and the relatives that I'm going to
talk about after the break
[Applause]
thank you
yeah so in the last slide of two slides
before
breaking yeah
basically break-in generator makes sense
only if a break-in generator will give
you something interesting so your
generator must have some special
properties like reconstruction
properties that's in
effect something
that has the construction property where
do those properties come from
usually like in settings generator or
complexity generators you say that my
generator is going to be super random
good because if you assume that my
function after the generator is based on
is of high circuit complexity for
example
and the way you prove that my generator
will be good if function f is hard is by
getting this reconstruction algorithm
okay so in some way you have like this
your proofs of something being good are
constructive
okay to prove that heart function f and
plastic generator is good is done in the
in the opposite direction by saying okay
break my generator I challenge you then
I get your circuit for breaking it and
make a small circuit for f from that and
that's the construction property of the
generator
um another example would be for like
aircrafting codes decoding aircraft in
codes right you say I can decode with
some error using if you give me a
message which meant almost matches the
encoded version of the message then I
can correct for some few errors
so if you
and um
the hybrid arguments of course are very
useful in to randomness setup so usually
one the first step you do when you say
that you can break the generator by
distinguisher from random you can stop
by the hybrid argument and say oh
therefore I can predict one of the bits
of the generator and then go from there
so 100 arguments definitely loose there
and that's why I use this the generator
versus the uniform
bits of the generator and then use their
properties of the generator drawing
something good from
that's what we can submitted some data
yes so you said that all you need for
the learning algorithm is an average
case or heuristic
algorithm for mcspr natural proof
and we don't know any worst case version
methods but can you think of any clever
way to use a the worst case version of
it is there anything known about
follow if we did it inside the steps if
I were if I had a worst case would I get
a better learning algorithms
okay
we should have some kind of work
shouldn't have
and just I think it is
yeah properly proper um very good yeah I
meant to say this so here it's like an
improper learning because the circuit
that I get for my ac0 multi-function
will definitely not basis your MLP
circuits I forgot to mention it's
important so this is interesting like
for improper learning we have an
algorithm here
I'm not sure we have any algorithm I'm
pretty sure we don't have any algorithm
that properly alerts this is 0.p but I'm
not sure if we have some like barriers
to that maybe some crypto space do you
know
just a really good question to see if
the distinguisher is ac0p like does the
analysis give you that the learner the
the thing you get out is AC group error
correction yeah there's also some air
correction going on like outside
because
I think uh Rahul and Inger looked into
this and I think the best take would
come up with like tc0
or you know the construction thing for
the complexity because the activity was
enough
so it seems like in some sense you could
think of this as kind of like a search
decision reduction right because it's
like I have a decision algorithm or mcsp
and I'm using it to absolutely yes
absolutely yes so you have a decision
algorithm for friendship speed and you
use it to find a small circuit which is
holding a search version of them with
some caveats that is approximation
rather than the exact circuit right and
it's not really like Optimal size but
like there's all penal size but other
than that yeah I see lots of one is a
bit super efficient but it can be like
[Music]
Okay so